I will call The Joint fiscal committee
meeting to order on February January
19th and the first order of item is
acceptance of the minutes of December
15th so
move
Senator gray moves acceptance seconded
by Senator dallis Sandro any additions
or
Corrections hearing none of you all
ready for the question all in favor say
I I oppose no the minutes are adopted
moving on to Chairman could I abstain
please because I representative I not
here so I'd like to
abstain can't hear me yes I was not not
at the meeting so I'd like to oh all
right you're abstaining thank you Mr
chair you be abstained Mr chair and
slow and okay representative Edwards
abstains okay we have a consent calendar
that goes from tabs three through nine
excuse me Mr chair um just tab two is a
tabled item if anyone wants to REM that
item any requests on
that I'll request to take it off the
table all right Senator bird cell remove
um wishes to remove it from the table is
there a second second all in favor of
removing it from the table say I I
oppose no it's removed from the table
and item FIS 20 3 344 is before us
business and economic
Affairs we have someone from the agency
direct
cogwell good morning good morning
ba Chase Hegman director of Economic
Jesus question representative bdel
Senator bdel um I don't Mr chair I don't
have a question but I do want to um um
make a comment I spoke with uh it was I
think it was tabled because of my
basically my requests based on the fact
that um we had a trade Mi a New
Hampshire trade mission to Poland this
uh fall which I was grateful to attend
um trying to get and I understand that
some of that is on me but you know
trying to get a stien back uh after
spending $6,000 of my own money and this
uh legislators only make $100 a year um
the
um we discussed it on the phone
yesterday and I do I I think we're going
to work on trying to get maybe a line
item in the budget next time in the
future for in case any of these um trade
missions come up that the legislators or
elected officials I know if the governor
goes he's got his own budget but we
don't
so if there's another um chance that
there's a trade Mission I think there's
a line item that any elected officials
can use at least just to pay for their
um their tra their um airfare and their
no so anyway we are going to work on um
something for the future did you put in
a request through the Senate budget
I've there is money in there for
travel I'm working on it okay Mr
you all right
so I have six items that have been
removed from cons don't we have to
right I will move the item okay
second all right motion to accept item
23 344
uh Senator birdell Senator gray further
discussions pet representative
leean thank you Mr chairman so there is
an
$8600 appropriation or line for travel
on this particular item so none of that
can be used to reimburse you is that
what we're told oh that's a question my
understanding is no this is federal
money um so the the uh trade mission was
New Hampshire
based thanks so that's correct director
can answer that question you're welcome
so can any of that money be used to
reimburse or travel no sir we we've
looked at that and it's said these are
federal dollars so there there are um
unfortunately limitations that are
placed on how we use those funds um and
they're directed exclusively at small
small businesses and their and their
costs a portion of their costs when they
travel
abroad but but as Senator mentioned that
we we did discuss some options that we
we could potentially look at going
forward that I think would maybe remedy
that
situation thank you Mr chairman further
questions seeing none we have a motion
in a second to adopt the
item all in favor say I I oppose no it's
adopted all right to the consent
calendar the items that I've had
following under
tab
five
24027 that was from the Senate and also
I have a House member with a
24032 House member requested that
removal under tab
six
member and under Tab
24025 is that is that six no yeah no
that was seven T seven that was that was
tab seven one two three four that was
the fourth one okay two more on the tab
eight Tab 8
24005 under tab
a are there any further items wish to be
removed from the consent calendar
um
I think that one of the Senators did ask
for something she's resent did
that I did I'm sorry I try not to copy
everybody but I told Mr Kane I didn't
want to remove it from consent anymore
correct you're you're correct you want
we got some exp repetition of the other
ones from the department so I no longer
want to remove
2006 006 what you said was good the L
you had perfect the rest are okay all
right so to make it to make it easier
the senator had a question the question
resolve the issue and now she does not
want to pull it okay which item was that
24006 okay I I don't I did did not
mention that for removal correct so it
is still on the consent calendar yes all
right how does the committee wish to
proceed consent
calendar Senator gray moves acceptance
of the consent calendar with those a
four mentioned um exceptions Senator
dallesandro
seconds further discussion seeing none
are ready for the question all in favor
say I I oppose no we we'll first move so
the consent calendar is accepted with
those exceptions mentioned the first one
we will come to will be under
tab
five
2427 I think
it's what's the what's
the yeah
testing and that would be the health and
are Senator rosenwall did you have a
question I did thank you Mr chairman I
actually had a couple of questions one
is for
Dees um who sent some further
explanation this morning saying
that the the money that was appropriated
in 2019 for the drinking water in
groundwater test which I think was
between1 and a half and $2
million they were unable to use so they
ended that Grant
um my question is did wasn't that non
labing
how where where is what is that money
doing now sure Senator so that's a
question that Dees uh Su Carlson will be
a to answer has to do with the fiscal
year 2019 appropriation from the
drinking water and groundwater trust
fund for schools was that
Doe um
yeah good morning um for the record my
name is Susan Carlson Environmental
Services the money that we are giving
Health and Human Services is actually
coming from a Federal grant primarily
and then $400,000 from the drinking
water groundwater trust fund the money
we had given the Department of Education
that you were referring to um that Grant
has been closed and was returned to the
money could I follow up yeah follow what
was the mechanism for returning the
money that we appropriated to the
trust
the when I when I say return the money I
mean the Department of Education
um we ended the grant with them it's not
an actual cash transfer um we ended that
Grant with them because um of um they
were not spending the money and we
pivoted for the lead in schools and dayc
carees because of changes in law to um
work with Department of environment
excuse me of Health and Human Services
to deal with lead in um Child Care
Centers and Dees itself is handling
grants directly to the schools for lead
remediation I follow thank you could you
provide us with the statutory language
that allowed you to do that and my
second question is for HHS and that is
how many child care facilities are going
to receive these grants to have their
water uh drinking water sources upgraded
to to be led free sure good morning uh
to the committee my name is Ian W I'm
the interm director for uh division of
Public Health Services so there are 717
licensed uh child carees in the state of
New Hampshire we anticipate up to 20%
may need some kind of lead remediation
activities and those would largely be
fixture we we anticipate most of them
would be fixture Replacements um we're
hoping there aren't as many kind of
broadscale water system impacts
obviously those are more costly and and
would impact the funds available um but
everyone would be eligible for these
funds and we anticipate it may be
between 100 and 150 facilities that may
need
item Senator rosenal moves the item
Senator bird cell seconds it I recognize
representative Edwards did you have a
question on this
item uh no sir okay any further question
seeing none are you ready for the
question all in favor say I I oppose no
2432 this one I had uh representative
item good morning again Susan Carlson
Environmental
Services hi thank you for taking my
question so I asked about what
communities would be served and the
answer came back well you can't really
tell me until you get the money and go
through the process so I would ask if
once you've gone through that whole
process you get to the point of the
communities being served could you
provide back to fiscal um that
information certainly that'd be great
thank you and should I just continue
I'll stop no no go ahead the other one's
the same thing but we should prob vot
first okay that's what all you needed
that's all I needed any further
questions from committee I'll entertain
a
motion Senator Bradley move the item
Senator gray seconds for FIS
24032 are you ready for the question all
in favor say I I oppose no the item is
adopted moving on to tab
six
enironment of Environmental Services
again again representative F has a
question same qu same request if you
would thank you we'd like to get the
data
item motion by representative F to adopt
the item second by Senator dallesandro
or any further questions on 24033 seeing
none you're ready for the question all
Services represent
F and representative Lehman have
questions on this
item you want to introduce yourselves
first or should I start
first uh good morning I'm Ian watt I'm
the interim director for Public Health
Services good morning Nathan white Chief
Financial Officer Department of Health
and Human Services thank you for taking
my questions or question so I I posed
this I didn't get it answer but I
similar to the last folks that were up
if you could provide details of the
contracts for program Services when you
have when it's appropriate basically the
$200,000 of who those contractors are uh
you want specifically who the
contractors are yeah um yeah we can I
don't have that information in front of
you rep uh represent Lehman do you have
a question on this
item uh yes Mr chairman
thanks I was just curious I think it's
on page five I know these are all
federal but it talks about fund
components like under the notice of
awards a uh amd2
and NW SS2 what those are and yep two uh
AMD is Advanced molecular Diagnostics
it's specifically related to genetic
sequencing which we use for disease
identification in the event of a
foodborn outbreak or you know various
strains of infectious diseases it allows
our the public health Laboratories
within the division division of Public
Health Services to do genetic sequencing
and work with Partners to identify
specific strains of disease that may be
spreading in New Hampshire and then the
the data modernization uh is
specifically tied to uh electronic case
reporting um so reportable diseases in
the state that need to be reported we're
working with uh vendors on their
electronic case reporting as well as lab
case
reporting and NW
SS2 NWS to I will have to follow up with
you I do not have that
acronym in front of me right now sharp
too I I just never seen those before and
I just we have uh we have our associate
commissioner here to uh to save it good
morning Patricia Tilly associate
commissioner um uh NWS is our national
Wastewater monitoring oh okay
thanks thank you Mr chairman thank you
any further questions from the
Senator alisandra moves the item second
by representative Lehman for item
24025 further questions seeing none you
ready for the question all in favor say
I I oppose no 24025 is
got already did that all right so now
we're 24 on Tab
24003 Department of Business and
economic
Affairs good morning again Taylor
Caswell
commissioner and I head down uh
representative Lehman had a question on
this thank you Mr chairman so I see that
you have a remaining budget of about
$7.9 million and this particular item
expires if you will or ends in November
of next year are you going to be able to
spend all that money because you haven't
made many requests on it so far yes sir
uh absolutely I the the the issue has
been the design of the programs that we
are going to be bringing forward we have
to have those approved by the economic
development Administration so that's a
back and forth so as we get those
approvals we bring them here but we have
programs that are going to be showing up
over the next couple of months that will
get us on track to have those funds
spent well in advance of November of
chairman further questions I'd move the
item representative leishman moves
24003 seconded by Senator gray any
further questions seeing none you ready
for the question all in favor say I I
oppose no 24003 is adopted we're moving
245 Department of Health and Human
Services and I have down that uh
representative Edwards has a question uh
thank you Mr chair um it's good to be
back it's been 7 months so I hope I
remember how to do this but um I um I
specifically would like to get an idea
24005 uh under class
101 it it describes that the funds will
be used for U Medicaid Care Management
capit ation payments fee for service uh
provider payments uh
DCF uh Behavioral Services for clients
enrolled in uh New Hampshire's Medicaid
Program so um keeping in mind that I'm
for a full education on this I just
would like to understand better at maybe
a Layman's
language what this money is is going to
be spent on is this is this money going
to be spent because we've had increased
volumes is it going to be uh added to re
um reimbursement rates is it something
that we've actually have already owed
and this is going to give us an
opportunity to pay it just where where
does this money go sure um Nathan white
Chief Financial Officer held and Human
Services uh so I'm just going to back up
a little bit to put some of this into
context so this item is similar to an
item that was approved by this committee
last February um what we are approving
here this is this is met this is
additional met Revenue um when the
department budgeted last year or in the
summer of 2020 um that was obviously a
challenging time for many and when we
budgeted our Revenue within our Medicade
program account and so this is the 7948
this is the Medicaid Care Management
account this is the account from which
we and and class line in this specific
case from which we pay um our per member
per month rates we pay our fee for
Service rates so to directly answer your
question representative Edwards this
would be pay these funds would be
supporting the existing Medicaid Program
and the existing payments that that we
have the reason why you're seeing $39
million here this was $1 million in the
prior year is because when we made our
our Dish payment payments and that's
part of the larger disproportionate
share hospital um program in the prior
year we earned an additional 5% federal
funds that we Norm in a normal world we
would not have otherwise so we were able
to earn additional federal revenue
additionally going back to the summer of
2020 when we originally prepared the
state fiscal year 23 budget um we
budgeted conservatively because the met
the the Met revenues it's a 5.4% tax on
net patient service Revenue we assumed
at that point in time that Hospital's
net Patient Service Revenue was probably
going to be lower um that it we we had a
slightly different experience obviously
than than what we anticipated in that
year but in uh for example in 2021 the
Met Revenue came in at 248 million and
by state fiscal year 2023 met Revenue
was at 301 million um so so Statewide we
saw a large increase in that and so
today we're asking you to allow us to
accept these funds into the standard
Medicaid budget and this budget is Carri
forward from year to year uh it doesn't
lapse at the end of the bium um and this
would allow us to make provider payments
and if there are changes un you know
unpredicted changes um in enrollment
numbers or utilization um these funds
would would be used to pay for that but
they would not to answer your question
directly they would not be used to pay
for rate increases that was a separate
trch of funds um that this committee
already discussed back in
October followup followup question uh uh
thank you Mr White um for being gentle
with me on that so um what what I'd
still like to come back to is um a
commitment that was made uh when we were
all negotiating in good faith with each
other on on uh um Monies to be allocated
to the Medicaid reimbursement rate
increases and uh in a in I think in an
act of nobility the hospital system
stepped forward and said that they would
defer their share of a Medicaid
reimbursement rate so we could
distribute it far further across the the
community to help others and I'm just
curious if uh it happens that this met
money is uh going to be um an
anticipated benefit to the hospital
system that would rightly deserve it but
I'm just curious where where we are in
terms of keeping track of um our
commitments and
Promises does that make
sense is this is this met money going to
the hospitals no so the the the Dish
payment um program that that's that's
articulated within the 2018 settlement
agreement and RSA
um those payments are based on the
methodology specified therein um this
These funds would not be used to
increase those payments These funds
would be used to pay for and support the
Medicaid
Program all right uh thank you with I'm
satisfied I think Senator Rosenwald may
have a question Senator Rosenwald for
question thank you following up on
representative Edwards though don't the
hospit hospitals account for the
majority of
Medicaid claims or a huge chunk of it so
won't some of those increased provider
payments ACR to the
hospitals the even though we didn't give
them a rate increase the the the the
payments are based on utilization so it
it would be based on where the need is
like
there this is essentially going into our
larger Medicaid a program account 7948
it's one of the largest accounting units
in the state um and it's used to support
that program so I I don't see any direct
relationship or incentive or causality
associated with this accept an expend
and and any outcomes associated with
what what you were indicating Senator
Rosen wal fur question thank you so the
the fact that we have this pretty
significant excess met
Revenue has has the
department tried to figure out to what
extent it's caused by increased
utilization and to what extent it's
caused by increased
prices I would have to check with the
Medicaid team to know if they've
conducted that kind of level of analysis
at this point though I'm not aware of
one but Henry limpin just stood
up try to help good
observation good morning for the record
Henry Litman the state's Medicaid
director so the the Met tax money that
funds the dish that the the arrangement
that is codified in 2018 House Bill 1817
we F fulfilled that completely Our
obligation on that um in terms of this
um additional met tax it was expected to
cover things
um in terms of the enrollment um other
growth and services but in terms of your
directly on your question um we saw
typically the Met Revenue has been
growing in more typical years between
three and 7% um is what what we see net
Patient Service Revenue growing in the
hospitals that drives the tax collection
to go up um but keep in mind the reason
some of this is continually
appropriated just one example is um as
we look at next year we have um
identified at least
66 um new Gene therapies and and drugs
that are potentially coming at the
Medicaid Program um some of them um you
know we think in the end we probably
about 31 will come in the next
year when I say these 31 they have a
minimum cost of
$200,000 and some um like for example
the the one on sickle cell anemia the
prices on those are 2.1 and three
million there is a rebate that we get on
it but you know in terms of the 39 39
million is a big uh dollar amount but
some of the uncertainties in terms of
where spending is going to go as a
result of these types of things that
that's I think why the past legislature
has given um some difference to this
additional money because we have
enrollment um variation which has been
you know it's settling down more to what
we expected right now um but all these
other things coming at us that that's
why I think that money is intended to
support that and you know other
utilization changes as uh as uh Nathan
helps thank you director any further
questions from the committee members
Senator Bradley moves the
item second by Senator Rosenwald is
there any further discussion
seeing none you ready for the question
all in favor say I I oppose no the item
is
dock I see the director is here any
questions on
dock r represent Lehman moves the item
2415 is there a second second by Senator
dallesandro further discussion seeing
none all in favor say I I oppose no 2415
is
adopted we had some questions on some of
the some of the information items uh
we've all gotten a new hand out on the
Youth Development Center claims
Administration uh does anybody have any
questions on that the item we've gotten
recently
2434 yes I've one all right
representative Earth has a question
someone here from I see the Attorney
General is
here
okay and two two of the other people in
that program good
morning button here can can you hear me
does that work get a little closer okay
I'm Jen Foley I'm general counsel for
the YDC settlement fund I'm working with
administrator brri um and I can hear
walk through the report answer questions
about the report whatever you'd like if
you want to have a walk through go first
I who wants to go first I can go first
but I wasn't about a breakdown okay
representative Earth um I just have a
request if you could provide us some
future point of a breakdown of the claim
sizes you know are they all coming in
one and a half million or some of them
you know a lot of between zero a half a
million that kind of thing just get an
idea of the span of claims that are
awarded claims not not the requests but
the what you
actually um finally resolve thank you so
if I understand so for settled amount
such as by the Attorney General's office
or through resolution proceeding whether
it's zero to 100,000 awarded 100 to some
typee of range like
that yeah that'd be great okay sure
thank
you
okay further questions on the item from
committee members seeing
motion you don't need a motion we don't
need a motion it's only an
information thank you all
right you don't have any more questions
no no I'm done all right someone had a
question on
2416 and Health and Human
Services
representa Edwards is recognized for a
question uh thank you Mr chair um this
is a report that uh I've seen in various
iterations over the last couple of years
and one of the takeaways of this report
tends to be that the legislature has
once again um fully appropriated all the
money that would be necessary to have a
zero weight list and it's been a long
time since I've had an opportunity to
ask qu the question is though is um how
are we doing on the ground I know that
we've appropriated all the money um I'm
glad we've done that and we've done that
for two or three years now but the
question that I had asked um
periodically was uh are all of the kids
who are eligible for services actually
receiving them we we we used to have a
gap between the kids that we had money
for and the kids that had providers
because not everybody had the providers
they needed so we were long time ago
looking for a metric to give us some
idea of how healthy we are at
kids um thank you for the question um
representative Edwards um for the record
Chris santinello associate commissioner
this report here is geared towards the
child care Development Fund funding and
children needing access to a subsidy um
we don't have a um collect a weit list
for children who who do not receive
these funding who are looking for
placement in a child care
setting so so let me restate that
because I think I understand you but
what I think I just heard you say is um
uh we don't have any kids that are
eligible that don't also have a a
matching to a provider at this point we
don't
have data we don't have any children who
are eligible for the child Child Care
scholarship funding who are waiting for
that
funding so that's that's all good news
right there's nothing hidden in there I
should be picking on that sounds all
good I don't think so I mean but this is
funding and so I
think yeah well and the funds if they
don't get used they they're non-aps are
they
not
the I the federal funds carry over
year to year okay um and then I think I
had another question um we changed the
eligibility for this program in hb2 I
believe um and we were curious what the
status is on the eligibility update so
that just went into effect um January
1st January 1 it went into yes so I
don't really have data on that you just
did that was the answer okay thank you
perfect yeah okay um that's all the
questions I have on this that's all okay
all right do you have one anybody else
have any questions on this item thank
you I think we also have
2426 yes sir we had question from I
think Senator
Six
I'm not hearing you with your mic
off I also had questions on the
litigation fund but while the department
is here I had a
question about the the
dashboard the long-term care program the
CFI
numbers which were projected to rise and
be just under 6,000 and have continued
to fall and are
currently this fiscal year and last
fiscal year below where they were pre
pandemic and the nursing home bed census
is also down versus goal so my question
is where's the bottleneck in the
department and and what is the
department doing
to um get more more
people uh provided with the services
they're eligible for and are approved
for thank you for the question um I'm
Melissa Hardy I'm the division director
for long-term supports and services so I
think a couple of things um that we're
doing to to increase the supports in the
community Through the CFI program one is
the legislation in hp2 for the system of
care for healthy aging um looking at
eligibility um requirement ments and how
we get that streamlined for folks to uh
be eligible for Medicaid and services in
the community um so we're actively
working um on on those Provisions that
were uh appropriated in hp2 the other
um uh program we're working on is Money
Follows the person we are um submitting
our operational protocol to CMS at the
end of this month and we should also see
a correlation
in Community Based Services um for
people accessing Services through money
person thank you thank you is the
department meeting its statutory
deadline for the
determinations yes yes for for Medicaid
determinations for long-term care yes
waiver yes thank
you any further questions on that item
yes
sir representative Edwards um thank you
Mr chair um there's there are some
tables here that paint a potentially
interesting short story um tables um one
two three uh where it looks like the
amount of workload going through
Medicaid has been
dropping quite a lot and I know some of
this is from the Department's efforts to
um um modify
eligibility but is there more going on
to Behind These charts that would
present a couple of sentences of a short
story well the on on page one t table
one that that's that's referring to the
total count um on page two if if you're
looking at Medicaid case loads I mean
what you're seeing there is the
unwind um that's the significant drop
that that we're seeing there um
utilization in tanif I mean that's
there's been a downward Trend there for
quite quite some time so I'm not I'm not
necessarily drawing any other
conclusions there what what what were
you thinking representative efforts well
I'm just seeing a a kind of an
unexpected to me drop in Medicaid
utilization and and some of it seems to
be associated with with the unwind but
I'm just curious if there's something
deeper beneath the the the the
decline uh that would indicate a
healthier population or a population
that's harder for us to access or you
know I'm it just it just alerts me that
something seems to be odd no I I mean
the the unwind trans that took period
over a period of 9 10 12 months or I
guess not quite 12 but um that's been
going on for a period of time that's why
we see a slow gradual um decline there
but B basically what what we're seeing
like in standard Medicaid is a return to
you know pre pandemic levels so I I I
mean Henry litman's here he can
certainly speak to it more in depth but
um I'm not aware of anything unusual
there ju just shake your head if you
think that there's something more
unusual going on there otherwise I'll
leave
it
we we can we can talk later I want to
talk to you about Opthalmology
anyways uh all right and then uh I would
like to jump forward to Table Six this
is the U
cunu U
Services and in the last six orth six
months or so uh we've been hitting an
average daily census of 18 pretty
commonly and this makes me
nervous because um I I thought we were
going to be able to build the new cunu
center uh with
18 realizing that 18 was a maximum
number that we needed in a flexible
situation but if but logically if we're
at 18
regularly then we've given up our
flexibility and and we may be in sort of
a red situation already I'm I'm curious
what you what you think did did I screw
up by not telling you to build 20
instead of
18 uh good morning uh Marissa hen Deputy
Commissioner uh for the record it's
really Mr ribson by the way Miss yeah we
screwed up it's oh oh we can blame it on
our dcyf predecessor so um you are right
that the census at syc has been high for
the past year um part of that seems to
be due to some of the changes in what
we're seeing around Juvenile Justice
related to um Gang Related activity and
also the number the seriousness of
crimes is resulting in more youth being
committed meaning they're spending
longer sentences versus that short
detention period so there's been a bit
of a shift just in the overall landscape
of Juvenile Justice not only in New
Hampshire but in other states um so
we're doing a number of things in
response to that because it has been
made uh exceedingly clear to us not just
last session but for many sessions that
18 is the limit for the um New YDC build
so the things that we're doing are first
of all we're working to actually
continue to drive that number down by
doing all the preventive Upstream work
of getting kids and fam services that we
know make a difference um I won't detail
those for you but you've you've heard me
talk about them before um the second
thing is we're working with the court
system to say what should we do in that
situation we're obviously still a couple
years out from the new YDC being
um you know accepting youth but we need
to be prepared so those are essentially
what we're doing we're working to to uh
to lessen the actual um uh demand and
then we're actually working in the event
that the the demand exceeds Supply um
working with the court system who are
the only ones who can order youth to the
uh YDC in the first place to say um what
would we do in that situation because
the the future build is um an 18 Max
exception
question follow up follow up so it it
seems like the trend in the growth is in
the uh detained youth
column and and that the committed youth
column is has been pretty stable for
quite some time and so is it the court
system that may be able to work with you
the most to influence the detained youth
or is that all prescribed by law um so
essentially when I'm referring to the
increase in committed I'm comparing it
to last year at this time when you see
the number was around two or three and
now is around six so it's really that
change from a year from when the
legislation passed where we had a census
I think of around uh 12 um on average to
that that higher number so so the
problem with committed and detained and
actually we're in the process per a
really thoughtful request from
representative wner to update this to
show um the cumulative number of
admissions because looking only at
detained or committed is a bit of a
misleading snapshot the detained youth
are sometimes only there for a couple
days a few weeks the committed youth are
often there for years um sometimes the
the uh remainder of their minority um so
so I think the the answer to your
question is we are seeing an increase
we're seeing a change in the composition
in population this isn't just New
Hampshire this is happening regionally
and nationally um and yes it requires
working with the courts because DHHS
can't actually decide who goes to YDC um
we uh rely on the courts and working
with the courts to make those
determinations based on very strict
criteria I I appreciate your answer
thank you thank you Mr
chair senator birdell for a question
thank thank you taking my question um
understanding that the YDC the the new
YDC is going to have an 18 bed Max is
up
thanks so again I think that the
situation is one of it's not entirely up
to just DHHS um even now let's say um
there was a major incident you know of
an array of criminal activity that
resulted in 10 kids being sent to syc
today we could not accommodate that with
our staffing with our facility with our
ability to meet federal regulations for
separating youth um in a way that's safe
so it's not it's never out of the
question that the um demand for services
could exceed Supply and I think it would
require um just careful conversations
with the courts to say we have to come
up with Alternatives we have to find
ways to get some of these youth into
residential treatment we have to make
sure all of them are actually
appropriate um and can't be served
elsewhere don't require psychiatric
treatment so so it's never it's not like
the possibility isn't always there um I
think we're taking it much more
seriously given the concern that you've
raised that we're we're awfully close to
now any further questions from committee
much if there's no further questions on
the informational items we'll move on to
the I'm sorry Senator rosemal yes I had
a question on the litigation report from
the Department of Justice okay I see the
Attorney General is here we'll move back
to oh it's number 2434 under tab 11 yeah
thank you absolutely good morning um um
page three of the 2023 report yep I just
wanted to ask you about two items there
are no line numbers but they're the two
expensive it items the first one is GK
at all versus Christopher sonunu at all
is that an ER boarding case no Senator
that that is that's not ER boarding this
is um a class action that was brought
against uh the state by four uh four
youth who are in foster care but but
have um have mental
disabilities so they that is basically a
challenge to
how whe whether the state is doing what
it needs to be doing under the law to
provide services for kids who might be
in foster care that that have mental
disabilities okay thank you yep and um
my second question is down almost at the
bottom
investigation YDC it's $1.9 million are
those the criminal cases or is that yes
civil those are the criminal cases okay
yep thank you yep
thank you Mr
chairman representative lean for a
question thanks Mr chairman and thanks
for being here you do a staggering
amount of work which is obvious by these
two documents you've given us so I had a
couple of questions um one I saw the
conille line was about $850,000 is that
where does that stand now is that under
stay is it being repealed yeah so it it
well right now we filed the motion for
reconsideration but we we anticipate
that going up on appeal and we do not
expect the costs on appeal to be
anywhere close to what the costs were to
prepare the case for trial and actually
try the case okay thank you and just one
other question Mr chairman follow up I
saw a couple of Liquor Commission items
where you were involved are you being
reimbursed by The Liquor Commission for
that any of that litigation
or I I don't believe we get reimbursed
no we just we represent every everyone
we we used the litigation fund for for
that okay was something that former
representative Ober and I were always
concerned about that um the litigation
at least from The Liquor Commission
wasn't being reimbursed to the euro
office
but yeah so so um uh Kathy Carr was just
saying they do pay into swab for civil
so so they do like every other agency
sort of sort of pay in and there are
shared costs for an agency like ours
that that serves every agency in state
government so there is that
reimbursement that is sort of the same
as as other agencies but there's no
direct reimbursement we don't Bill The
Liquor Commission for litigation we do
for the Liquor Commission okay thanks
chairman any further questions from
committee
members seeing none thank you very much
thank
audits
blocking
good commissioner if if you don't if
you're crowded at that table you can go
to the mics at the end of the other
table as well I think we're going to be
okay
words
okay good morning Mr chairman and
members of the committee for the record
I'm Christine Young director of audits
for the
LBA um as you know we contract with KPMG
to conduct the Statewide audit of the
financial statements uh joining us from
KPMG is the partner Marie Zimmerman and
the prepar of the annual comprehensive
financial report from the Department of
administrative Services we have
commissioner Charlie Arling housee and
state comp controll or Dana call uh and
with that I'm going to turn it over to
Marie for the presentation of the report
thank
you thank you and good morning I am
honored to be back in front of you today
um this is my seventh time presenting to
you the annual financial statement
um of the State of New Hampshire I
wanted to say that this is not a small
lift it is a testament to Charlie Dana
and management for pulling it together
and for Christine and her LBA team who
proactively support us throughout the
audit we did not identify any issues um
or concerns as it relates to the
integrated audit throughout our
coordination with LBA um and we did
increase the use of their support
throughout our audit as well as
Technology support um that we were able
to bring and their team worked with us
as they Incorporated our technology into
their audit
process included in your package today
is a presentation um that includes our
required communication as well as the
results of our audit I'm not going to go
through Page by page but I'll just
summarize
briefly we did perform our audit in
accordance with governmental accounting
standards and we issued an
unmodified opinion which is the cleanest
opinion you can receive we issue opinion
on each of the major funds included
within the basic financials those are
the governmental funds the business type
activities and the aggregate driely
presented component units and each major
fund included in the aggregate remaining
information this also our opinion
includes references to other Auditors
and that larg is being the pension Trust
TR
funds we will be we did Issue an opinion
um related to the required supplementary
information that's an in relation to
opinion and that in required
supplementary information is the mdna
and the OPB and pension
schedules what that means is that we
subject the information in within those
three schedules to our audit procedures
to ensure that they were presented
fairly presented fairly in all material
respects with the audited financials
we have on Slide Five of our
presentation our required um
communication summarized there and I
just went through the key points that I
wanted to present now jumping to slide
seven um we have noted three uncorrected
audited adjustments and no corrected
audit adjustments these three um
management was aware of of and they
primarily relate to Corrections of
errors that were identified to ensure
that the financial stat for the current
year and going forward are
accurate we have received
representations from management and
concur that the effect of these
uncorrected financial statements and
related counseling and disclosures are
immaterial to the users both
individually and in the
aggregate if you will know on slide
eight we did not identify any material
weaknesses we do aine on internal
controls as relate to financial
reporting and material weakness with
would be the most severe level of a
breakdown of internal control so that is
a testament to your internal control
structure here at the state we did
identify one significant deficiency
which is a slight carryover from the
previous years as relates to the
unemployment compensation trust fund it
relates to the reconciliation of their
acrs on an annual basis that when I say
acrs I mean their acrel accounts
throughout the year they're on a cash
basis and at year end they'll they'll go
through a process of preparing for acral
reporting and it's the timeliness of
reconciling those accounts that we
reported on management is in concurrence
with that and continues to make efforts
to ensure they have the proper levels of
Staffing and support to be able to
perform those reconciliations in a
timely
manner we have issued a report on
internal controls over financial
reporting and compliance and other
matters on the audit of the financial
statements prepared in accordance with
governmental auditing standards within
that report we do identify that there
were no material weaknesses in internal
controls and we identify that one
significant deficiency I am the lead
partner on the federal single audit and
I'll be presenting to you in April this
letter will be included within the
federal single audit report that gets
filed with the with the federal
government the report um and lastly the
one I additional item I want to
highlight is that there were no dis
disagreements with management and there
was no significant dis difficulties
during the audit I felt that we had a
very strong working relationship and
Open Candid conversations and I do
appreciate that of management um to feel
confident in providing you with that
this opinion over the basic financial
statements does anyone have any
questions questions from the committee
you director commissioner
just I I won't belabor things but um
we've had a good relationship Marie was
actually the lead partner of my first
audit as commissioner and then she went
away and then she came back so that's a
that's a good sign I think I'm not sure
um uh we worked very uh closely and
cooperatively with both KPMG and LBA but
I want to make sure to uh to thank um we
have a very strong accounting staff um
in the state and in accounting services
and and you all know the com troller
very well but I want to make sure I
mentioned um Scott Egan who's our
director of financial reporting who's a
newer employee who did Yan's work on
this um so many times when I when I
stopped by the third floor would wander
down because there was only one light on
um late at night and hopefully he's
occurring lots of comp time um which is
a grand thing but and and Cat Bogan and
Deputy comproller um Karen Burke as well
so we have very good staff who did a
very good job on this um and it's why
the results are as good as you see and
I'm happy to note that during Dana's
entire
tenure the uh cfer has the Aur has been
on time which is unusual we all
appreciate
trola any questions on the comprehensive
annual financial report for this
team we're delighted to have it on time
and have it uh the results come out as
compliments
okay now we'd like to present the
turnpike systems annual financial report
uh KPMG conducted this audit the partner
Bob Mahoney will present the report and
joining us
also oh
sure okay all right Turnpike audit
Turnpike audit yes Bob Mahoney the
partner from KPMG will present the
report
and also joining us is Danielle Shand
denet Director of Finance from uh the
Department of Transportation and with
that I'll turn it over to Bob for the
presentation of the
report great thank you very much um you
should in your materials have uh three
deliverables related to the turnpike
system the first deliverable is the the
financial statements uh the second is uh
the report on internal control over
financial reporting and compliance
and the third is um the debt compliance
letter and before I go through each of
those uh quickly I just wanted to um
congratulate Danielle and her team for
all their efforts um during the audit
there a lot of lot of time spent uh
compiling the financial statements uh
timely and accurately so uh just wanted
to uh congratulate uh Danielle and her
team um with respect to uh the financial
statement opinion um that opinion
indicates that uh management is
responsible for the fair presentation
and uh accuracy of the financial
statements and KPMG is responsible for
expressing an opinion on the financial
statements um we conducted our audit in
accordance with generally accepted
auditing standards as well as Government
auditing
standards and that report uh also
references uh the report on internal
control of financial reporting which I
indicated earlier was the second report
in your uh materials that uh yellow book
report indicates that there were no
significant deficiencies or material
weaknesses identified uh during the
course of the audit so again um
congratulations to Danielle and her team
um and then the last report in your
materials the debt compliance report uh
indicates that we reviewed the
provisions and Covenants within the bond
resolutions and determined that uh the
turnpike system was in compliance uh
with those Provisions um so all good
news to report with respect to uh the
reports that you have in front of you um
in addition I will cover the required
Communications um to the committee so uh
there were no uh significant or unusual
transactions that we identified during
the course of the audit uh there was one
uncorrected misstatement uh which
relates to a nog Gap policy which is
consistent with uh uh uncorrected
misstatement that we have identified in
the past related to the allocation of
the net other post-employment benefit
liability um so the state does not
allocate The Trusted OPB um plan
liability to the Enterprise funds and
the Turnpike being one of those so um
again that's it's about a million dollar
uh net pension liability that was not
allocated so that was one uncorrected
misstatement that we identified there
were no corrected uh misstatements that
we identified during the course of the
audit um again there were no U material
weaknesses or significant deficiencies
identified uh we did discuss uh the
significant accounting policies which
are disclosed in the notes of the
financial statements uh with management
during the course of the audit um and
determined that they were reasonable in
addition we evaluated the uh significant
accounting estimates uh during the
course of the audit uh which included uh
the valuation of Investments uh the
valuation of the toll receiv receivables
allowance as well as uh acrs of expenses
and also determine those to be re
reasonable um there were no actual or
suspected uh illegal acts that we
identified during the course of the
audit uh there were no subsequent events
uh that we
identified uh no non-compliance with
laws or regulations uh no significant
difficulties that we encountered during
the audit um management did not uh
consult with other accountants uh that
we are aware of uh there were no uh
difficult or contentious matters that we
uh dealt with during the course of the
audit uh no disagreements with
management during the course of the
audit um and we are independent of the
turnpike um as well so with that um
that's all I have for prepared remarks
and um if you have any questions I Happ
to answer those and if Danielle has any
comments U that's fine as
well question so far from committee
members representative Lehman thank you
Mr chairman I noticed the accounts
payable from last year to this year seem
to be significant significantly Higher
by like $10 million are we paying our
or hi Danielle shandana I'm the Director
of Finance uh for the dot um we we
capture as much as we can we have had
some issues of with Staffing in AP so
they have drawn out a little bit but but
they're all paid up and we work on that
on a regular basis it's good okay so
just as Staffing issue and getting the
checks out typ yes all right thank you
thank you Mr
chairman thank
you any further questions from committee
morning
okay all here the next presentation will
be for the audit of the Lottery
Commission financial statements which
was performed by our office uh with me
is Kimberly Bisson she was a senior
manager on the audit uh who conducted
the audit
and uh joining us from the Lottery
Commission is Charlie McIntyre executive
director and Jim durus Chief Financial
Officer to respond to any questions that
you may have and uh with that I will
turn it over to Kimberly for the
presentation thank you good morning Mr
chairman and members of the committee
for the record my name is Kimberly Bon
we're here today to report the results
of our audit of the financial statements
contained in the New Hampshire Lottery's
annual comprehensive financial report
for the fiscal year ended June 30th
2023 the financial statements begin on
page 46 of the lottery Acer lotteries
management is responsible for the
preparation and fair presentation of
those financial statements in accordance
with generally accepted accounting
principles our Auditor's report and
opinion dated December 20th
2023 can be found on pages 27 through 30
in the financial section of the
report as noted in the opinion paragraph
on page 27
we issued an unmodified or clean opinion
on the lottery commission's basic
financial statements which also include
the notes and other supplementary
information while our opinion speaks
directly to the basic financial
statements and notes no matters came to
our attention that caused us to believe
that other information in the financial
section of the report was inconsistent
with the basic financial
statements auditing standards require
that we make a n number of disclosures
to you these disclosures are are
included in the other required
Communications handout that was provided
with you um provided with your
report in the interest of time I will
not go through each of them individually
however we can say that we were
satisfied with the cooperation of the
lottery and the progress of the audit
and there is nothing that we need to
bring to the committee's attention
related to any concerns with those
required
disclosures in accordance with
government auditing standards we will be
issuing a report on our consideration of
the Lottery's internal control over
financial reporting and on compliance
and other matters as a byproduct of our
audit that report will be included in
the management letter which will be
presented to this committee at a future
meeting um this concludes my
presentation I'd like to thank Lottery
Commission management and their staff
for their assistance during the audit
and with your permission I'll turn the
McIntyre uh good morning Mr chairman
members of the committee Charlie
McIntyre director Lottery uh I first I
want to thank the folks LBA for this um
they work collaboratively well with our
staff um but also I want to thank our
Chief Financial Officer Jim durus who
does this obviously remarkably competent
report but also really
good-look as always uh just you know
we're we're both real good at math and
we're real good at how things look so uh
want to thank the committee and answer
any questions you folks
have congratulations on a Very Good Year
to what do you attribute your 12.4%
increase they remarkable ability
um um essentially everything working
well um and um you take advantage of
natural occurrences right so Powerball
had a good year because interest rates
went up yeah and so jackpot sizes went
up because jackpots are a factor of cash
on hand times the bond factor which is
essentially interest rates that being
said New Hampshire was number one in the
country of Powerball sales so
yes it was a natural occurrence a
Tailwind but also we took remarkable
advantage of the Tailwind so um you know
the more I prepare you know the more I
prepare the better luck we have so
anyway and sports betting also we're
number two in the country of sports
betting profitability for the state
so yes we have natural occurrences yes
I'd like to thank the Dallas Cowboys for
losing because that alone um and
I I reminded commissioner capatos that I
thanked him personally and said we owe J
Jones a fruit basket so
uh anyway so number of good factors
really this past year was
a positive aspects of all on all LR
verticals congratulations further
questions from the committee
representative leean i' just like to
thank Charlie and his team because it
seems like ever since we stole you from
Massachusetts our revenues continue to
climb CL and just the note that $43
million just this year alone went into
the education fund so just want to thank
you and I know I speak for the whole
committee that you're doing a great job
I listen I I I have a wonderful team I
work with some of the most talented
folks I would note that since I started
we've gone from 62 million to 187
million and it hasn't been reflected on
my
salary just just to point just to point
out next budget session that's
all well Char think think of it this way
our salaries haven't increased in in a
in a 100
[Laughter]
years we should put you on bonuses
right just as some of your
staff any further
questions we're all delighted I
much
that
okay and last but certainly not least on
the agenda for today is the uh The
Liquor Commission financial statement
presentation this audit was also
performed by our office office and uh
with me to present the audit report
today is uh Jim lar Rivier he was the
senior manager from our office who
conducted the audit and uh joining us
from The Liquor Commission is Chairman
mik uh Chief Financial Officer Tina
demur and Chief Operating Officer James
Vera and now I will turn it over to Jim
presentation good morning chairman wer
and members of the committee again for
the record my name is Jim lavier we are
here today to report the results of our
audit of the financial statements of the
lior
commission commission's financial
statements in their annual comprehensive
financial report for the fiscal year
ended June 30th
2023 our auditor report and opinion
dated December 18th can be found on
pages 18 15 through 18 in the financial
section of the
report as noted in the opinion paragraph
on page 15 the financial statements are
presented fairly in all material
respects in accordance with generally
accepted accounting
principles an important item to note is
no material adjustments to the
accounting records were proposed as a
result of our audit while our opinion
speaks to the basic financial statements
and notes no matters came to our
attention that caused us to believe that
other information in the financial
section of the report was incon
consistent with the basic financial
statements auditing standards require
that we make a number of disclosures to
you which are included in the other
required Communications handout included
with your report in the interest of time
I will not go through each of the
disclosure requirements
individually however we can say that we
were satisfied with the cooperation of
the Liquor Commission and the progress
of the audit and there is nothing that
we need to bring to the attention of the
committee related to to any concerns
with those required
disclosures in accordance with
governmental auditing standards we will
include the report on our consideration
of internal controls over financial
reporting compliance and other matters
as a byproduct of this
audit in our management letter that will
be presented to the committee at a
future meeting I would like to thank the
liquor commission's management and staff
for their cooperation and assistance
throughout the audit this concludes my
part of the presentation and with your
permission chairman wer I'd like to turn
the presentation over to Chairman Mika
you thank you Jim morning morning
members of the committee uh Joseph mik
chairman of the New Hampshire Liquor
Commission with me is our CFO Tina
demier and coo uh James Vera we just
like to thank the LBA for the work that
they've done they're always
collaborative they're very helpful
and uh Jean and Jim and everyone that
comes over does great work I'd like to
thank Tina and her team they've done
wonderful work over the years uh We've
certainly uh come a long way at the
Liquor Commission given the audits that
we've had in the past and we're very
pleased with what the agency is doing
I'd be happy to answer any questions
that that you may have thank you thank
you questions from the
committee we're pleased that you're
having a good year in managing all those
stores and keeping everything moving any
challenges ahead that you
see well I think that you know we had
some challenges uh at the end of the
last fiscal year the weather wasn't
great we didn't have a great summer uh
we lost some of our large volume sales
from across but we're we're adjusting
our prices we've got some major
competition in Massachusetts with Total
Wine building eight stores there since
2016 uh so uh but we are doing our best
and we're up about
13 13 million thus far this fiscal year
so thank you thank you very much Mr
chairman Senator alisandra thank you Mr
I think it's it's
remarkable that the commission has done
as well as it has given the level of
competition I don't know how many of you
get the globe and listen to public our
public radio where where the competition
is advertising against us on our own
public system that's that's damn
difficult to deal with and and I think
the commission does a terrific job in in
sustaining its profitability and and
doing it doing the job properly so kudos
to the commission and everyone involved
and uh I'm I'm very very concerned about
the future based on a the level of
competition the fact that that the the
competitive the competitive Advent that
we once held doesn't really exist
anymore it's only through the efforts of
the commission that we sustain but
competition is severe at at this point
in time and this uh this local wine
situation that's a massive Corporation
massive Corporation and as I say they're
they're uh attacking us so kudos for the
job well done thank you Mr chair thank
you further from the
committee senator Rosal thank you what's
the vacancy
rate in your
stores from an employee standpoint uh
we're actually in pretty good shape
right at the moment the vacancy rate is
very low uh We've
basically uh given the 10% and we're our
opening uh salary is
1564 now so we've found that to be very
competitive and we've seen a lot of
people come back to the market that come
back to the part-time labor market that
weren't there as well as the incentive
program which has worked wonderfully
which is drawing some folks back to us
that wouldn't get incentives in these
positions in these retail positions in
other markets so thank you thank you
Senator I think that's worked out well
where you expanded your hours with
part-time people they were happy to get
the jobs and your customers were
certainly happy to get there in late
hours and on weekends so that was that
was a a big step appreciated that you
very much represent further from the
committee Senator Ro
Senator
bdel just a comment Hamstead would like
back it's all a matter of volume we
we're hoping everybody loves the new
Dairy Store Senator thank
you thank you thank you anything further
from the committee representative
Lehman well hearing Senator delis
Sandro's comments I just uh guess I'm
looking for how are we going to deal
with this declining Revenue based on all
the competition you're getting do you
have a plan in place or because
obviously it's having an impact on your
revenues well it hasn't had necessarily
had an impact in the revenues this year
going forward you were seeing it there
what we've done what the plan is to do
is to do greater discounting what we've
seen from Total Wine is you know they'll
literally on National Brands they'll
work on a penny a bottle two cents a
bottle uh they're a a private label
retailer so they'll work on 50 or 60%
markup on their private labels and give
away the national brand so by
discounting additional discounts uh from
15 to 20% Which has only driven our
gross profit down about a quarter of a
percent thus far given that we started
this program in July and we've run it
through uh we're seeing uh those folks
come back to us and buy here so it's
costing us a quarter of a percent to
become more aggressive across the border
and you know we have to we also have to
be concerned with the three states
around us that have cannabis because
there's additional funds there's only so
much funds that people have to spend
on uh you know these types of things and
we're seeing that in the three states
around us we're do they're doing just
under $2.5 billion doar in cannabis
sales Massachusetts did 1.75 billion
last year so the type of discretionary
income that normally would have been
spent on alcohol uh is being spent on
cannabis and when you see the Baby
Boomers moving out of the market there
you know the the folks born from 46 to
64 are moving out of the alcohol Market
the people moving in behind them the
generations behind them are buying less
alcohol and they're buying more cannabis
so we're seeing a split in that Revenue
being spent uh which is affecting the
alcohol business overall worldwide and
Nationwide we have a glut of wine in
France that they're pouring down the
drain they're pulling up they're pulling
up vines in Spain and in in in South
America America and they're planting
other crops because the the folks that
the Baby Boomers that drove the alcohol
market for many years are now aging out
and the people behind them don't drink
at the same pattern so it's something
that we're we're we're we realize and
it's something that we're working on
aggressively thank you Mr chairman
pleasure so Mr chairman I guess we ought
illegal Ro
[Laughter]
a
CL no he obviously has some challenges I
wonder if this U new business in
Massachusetts can sustain the low prices
they
have well being a national chain uh they
have they're in 24 25 States now they
have uh about 260 stores and uh you know
they're they're running somewhere just
under $4 billion in sales they have
13,000 employees Nationwide so they're
you know they're a big company and a lot
of the national National suppliers don't
necessarily like what they're doing with
dropping those prices and building a
knockoff brand against them but they're
such a huge brand that you cannot do
business with them so it's kind of
you're you're caught between a rock and
a hard place if you're uh if you're a
national supplier and so you have to do
business with them the the The Sweet
Spot for us is knowing that they do not
they do not have the type of inventory
that we have so when we put something on
sale we have tens of thousands of cases
to back that sale up they clearly do not
that they don't have that and they never
have so they disappoint consumer after
consumer that comes to those stores
looking for that for those products at
that price they may have six or seven
bottles so at at that particular price
and what we've seen in Massachusetts is
they're offering those low prices but
they'll be doing it in P particular
stores sometimes they'll say only
available in natic only available in
shoes Berry so they're they're moving
consumers around they're you know
they're playing a shell game with
consumers and we as a business do not do
that and I think our consumers are
responding to it aren't they paying hire
tax on wine and
mass well I think in general there
there's no sales tax on alcohol anymore
in Massachusetts it's been dropped it
was something that they put in place and
then they pulled away but there's talk
of it coming back and Praise Jesus that
it
does knowing the history of that state
as we do I think the taxes will go
back representative Earth thank you Mr
chair could you speak to the increased
23 those are primarily uh due to
salaries and benefits and our contracts
and rents for um our locations so the
rents have increased for the additional
Square footages for the new locations
that we've brought
on by 25% no but then there's the salary
and benefits are increase in debt so
there's many different factors that um
drive those cost up and do you expect
that to be the same going forward the
same kind of increases going forward um
not to that same level but we do have
the increase this year for the um pay
raise that went into effect the 10% pay
raise thank
you anything
further represent lean just backing up
to the last response that national chain
with a 260 some OD stores how Clos are
are they like in methu or at Kingsboro
are they right on the border now
or they started out with just one store
in naq was their first store uh but they
they have eight stores within 30 minutes
of our Southern Border in their furthest
store West is in on the shuberry
Northborough line and everything else is
inside the uh 95 495 Beltway so they've
taken that boss Market from the Rhode
Island border to our border and they've
kind of controlled that and it's caused
a lot of havoc in Massachusetts a lot of
people that were doing business there
for many many years have sold off their
businesses and sold to other entities or
you know Diversified the Cappies chain
which was in Massachusetts for years
completely sold out and they've they
just opened about two months ago their
first cannabis location the Cappies
family did thank you thank you Mr
chairman thank
you anything
else we appreciate this fine report
thank you very much for adapting to all
these
challenges thank you very much Mr
chairman we're doing our best thank you
you can take that to the
you all
right Mr Kane anything you want to bring
committee shall we tentatively set a
meeting I think Senator gray already
has the third
16th
anybody have any problems so far with
the 16th of February for the next
okay 10 o
[Laughter]
me not in February
beautiful put in a bill huh put in a
expenses I'll
F all right if there's nothing else I'll
entertain a motion to
adjourn second third and fourth all in
favor I we are adjourned thank you Mr
Kane thank you for all the the people
right